all right hello everyone how are you
guys doing hope you guys are having a
wonderful day today we're on the
merching account only but we're not
going to be going into the GE
necessarily however this video is going
to be about me talking about how to find
items to merge so this is pretty much
just going to be a video for the entire
series that I can reference back to if
you guys don't know what series I'm
talking about I just started a GE only
series it's not going to be around
building an account it's going to be
more around just you know I gave myself
1 GP and seeing what I can do obviously
this is a bit of a SP spoiler as I
already have 1.5 mil but there's more
stuff in the GE that I don't want to go
ahead and show you guys so if you
haven't checked that out go ahead and
check that out but for this video I'm
going to go ahead and talk about how to
find items that you would want to merch
and how to find items that have good
margins on them so we're not going to be
doing much in game so I'm going to go
ahead and get a better background for
this video all right this seems
relatively secluded so I'll use this
spot but what we're going to talk about
today is how to find items that you'd
like to merch and there's kind of a few
different tiers as far as merching goes
to try to to find items and I split that
up in this video into three tiers the
first tier being anything from 1 GP to
10 mil the second tier being 10 mil to
100 Mil and the highest tier being 100
Mil to whatever cash amount you have I'd
imagine for people with bills you
probably know how to work the grand
exchange but maybe I'm assuming too much
and maybe you're more of a pvm person so
I'll go ahead go through all those and
naturally we will start off with the 1
GP to 10 mil so this is a really weird
area uh of merching you're not going to
be making enough money per hour to outdo
anything else in the game really uh with
merching there's kind of this thing
where you should always be doing it on
an ALT account or on the side on your
main you should never be merching as
your sole source of profit as you guys
know this is the second account that I
use to merch and gain money on I would
never merch solely on an account unless
you're doing a lot of high-profit high
volume items in which you constantly
have to be there flipping them and
that's possible there are are times
where you can make more money than you
would doing anything else in the game
however for the most part that's not
usually the case so we go ahead and
start with the 1gp to 10 mil and the
first kind of item set that I want to
talk about is the high volume items with
all right margins so basically my
examples that I can tell you guys here
are pretty much herbs and Herb seeds so
uh pretty much renars anything like that
um RAR seeds Snapdragon seeds those
usually have pretty good margins all the
seeds for some reason have about a th000
margin you can buy 200 of them so it's a
really good margin to get every now and
then but just by me saying that that
might hurt the margin zor scales are
just your your base you can buy 30,000
of them they usually have a 1 to2 GP
margin it's a free 30 to 60k whenever
you want to do it uh ores ores I'd
recommend something like gold ores or
maybe coal those would be kind of the
two that I'd run with um I mean Rune and
adamant and mithil stuff like that does
get bought and sold however I don't know
if it's good enough I think coal and
gold are usually the place to be as far
as the logs um you and Magic really
Redwood I wouldn't imagine get bought
and sold too often as the average player
isn't going to use them even though I
think they are the best XP in the game
and runes I usually do death and blood
runes but you can do whichever ones you
please along with this those are more of
the high volume items where you'll be uh
flipping maybe a little bit quicker
there are some low value items that you
can go ahead and do and so this is what
I would recommend probably clue scroll
type items that's what I usually go with
um something along the lines of like
page sets gilded items such as gilded
plates legs Helm I mean all of it has
pretty good margins I don't usually mess
around with the plate skirt since it
doesn't get bought and sold too much um
like lower level ornament kits uh dragon
Defender Fury ornament kit maybe torture
if you have six mil stuff like that they
always have pretty good margins and for
the most part go ahead and just kind of
you know mess around with that and
you'll find some items that you like
just look up a list of clue scroll items
and for the most part like they all have
really good margins but they don't get
bought and sold that much because
they're mainly cosmetic so they don't
have a huge demand from there we go into
the barrows armor for low levels um I
mean you know your your average stuff um
you can do I mean really like anything
as far as barrows goes and nowadays
guthans used to be a little too pricey
to do with or with a 1 to 10 mil cash
check um but now pretty much anything's
up for grabs and usually they all have
pretty decent margins it's kind of your
your good starter set for merching those
items are just guaranteed decent profit
you kind of get to know the ropes a
little bit on top of that focus a lot on
God dehes is what I know um just as far
as like clue scroll loot go uh God dehes
God dehy boots are really good and so
all of them pretty much have good
margins so now we're going to go ahead
and get on into the medium tier so with
the medium tier obviously being 10 to
100 Mil there are a few different things
and I mean most of this is what you'll
see at the Grand exchange and this is
something that I'll offer up to people
um as kind of an idea if you're sitting
at the Grand exchange and you do not
know what to merch um something that
I've utilized in the past is the idea of
just h hoing to different worlds looking
around at people's armor and merching
that because obviously if the person's
wearing that armor it's in demand at
least somewhat and for the most part it
just kind of gets you an idea as far as
what different things to look for the
more obscure something is um that you
may not know exactly what it is I might
have a bigger margin so go ahead and
check it out but that's something that I
do but let's get on into the notables
that I have here so we're starting off
with God Wars armor now this is a big
one everyone thinks to Merch this
everyone is like what can I merge
they're like boom God War stuff because
it's it's high value people want it but
it's not necessarily the best because
everyone has this idea and I got to log
back in some things that I would
personally recommend are the armadel
crossbow usually a pretty good margin um
not a lot of people think of it I don't
think um typically people go with Bando
armor and armadil armor however armadil
armor is the exception still still has
decent margins I don't know if that's
because of the recent update though uh
zami spear hostas are really good and
armadil as I said before along with the
SGS from what I've noticed Bandos and zy
godswords don't have that much of a
margin because everyone thinks of uh God
War stuff to merge and people with a low
cash tag would think to those two items
since those are the cheapest that people
actually want and with armadil you have
all the people that think of it because
it's pkers so SGS typically pretty good
um I like it a lot along with the SGS
you kind of have the um Abyssal budgeon
I know it technically isn't God Wars but
kind of the same item as far as price
range and relatively good margin um
along with that the second kind of uh
little niche of pieces that I would
recommend would be low tier rate items
so stuff like Dragon Hunter crossbows
pretty good Twisted buckler Arcane
scroll and ancestrial hat all of these
are pretty good you could probably throw
a dragon Harpoon in there that that has
a decent margin every now and then uh
raids armor for the most part always has
really good margins mostly because it's
very volatile um prices do raise and
lower a lot with this kind of stuff so
you have to be careful and kind of know
where the market's at with them and
what's going going on as far as the game
goes on top of that we have Slayer drops
now these are Slayer drops that are a
bit higher you know kind of thing like
the for the for the average person like
merching Slayer drops you would think
wouldn't be all that great because you
think of whips dark bows none of that's
really that good but what I'm here for
today is Prim boots Pagan boots both of
those really good margins eternals
actually sometimes have a good margin
and along with that the two main Slayer
drops from superiors are really good so
that goes with the imbued heart and
Eternal gem Eternal gems a little worse
but I mean the abbut heart's really nice
and the Eternal gem is at least worth a
thought along with that since I said the
interal gem I'm kind of along the lines
of the eternal glory that has a decent
margin every now and then and as you can
see we uh we got some merges going on uh
but yeah so the eternal glory has a
decent margin a lot of the time it's
really weird and then along with that we
have the master SL Elite rewards now as
I said earlier Cosmetics always have
just a ton of margin for no reason but
basically what I'd recommend with this
is pretty much any ornament kit like
ornament kits um they're not really in
high demand and they're not in that much
of high Supply like no one stocked up on
them as soon as you get one you're
throwing it away to someone else and
once you have one unless you're getting
clean you're probably not taking it
apart to sell the ornament kit because
you don't even recognize it really oh
poor guy um but yeah so stuff like Fury
torture cult godsword ornament kits all
of that really good really good margins
there um on top of that ring of coins
and nature your ring actually not too
bad I mean they have decent margins a
relatively low cost and so they're not a
bad item check out if you can now on to
the 100 Mila one bill area this is
something that I have ventured into on
my main account this being my main
account at the time I had a bill so I'm
someone that's tested some of these
items um I don't have the best
information on high high price stuff
because I never got to it but we'll go
ahead and get on into it so third age
armor something I'd recommend um plate
bodies and plate PL legs really good
margins on those they always have a
consistent 4 to 500k you'll be lucky
sometimes to get a mil to 2 mil um so
yeah plate plate legs body are
consistent same with the magic robe top
it's actually it's actually really good
I don't know why it's relatively cheaper
piece of third age but I'm guessing it's
like you know it's just one of those
really cool items it's actually kind of
useful along with that you have some
stuff that I can't give a whole lot of
input on as I've never merched them
myself but I see all the time that they
have crazy margins and that is a pickaxe
Hatchet sword and Cape I do not know how
to merch these personally although I do
know that they are good good merges as I
see them all the time on G tracker just
having the craziest of margins but
there's a lot that goes into it because
some of sometimes these items don't even
buy or sell in the GE in a day's time so
you kind of have to be really patient
with them get out of here anyways on
from there we have the high tier raid
armor so yeah this is going to be I mean
this is going to be about everything you
can think of as far as raids go claws
ancestrial Elder Maul Twisted bow and
the Kodi wand pretty much all stuff that
you're going to want to go ahead and
merch they all have pretty good margins
Twisted bow I would love to merge like
I'd love to make a video just merching
Twisted bows or alians um just oh God
like margins but they're very volatile
and that's what makes them have such big
margins if they were guaranteed margins
they wouldn't be they wouldn't be that
profitable and now on to the final
little set that we have and that is
Spirit Shields Arcane spectrals and
Ellies but Arcane and spectral usually
have a couple hundred thousand of a
margin and Ellie is actually really
crazy it always just has the craziest
margin sometimes gets up to 2 to three
mil um something but I mean obviously
that's because no one knows how useful
the Ellie is right now and so people are
just Panic selling Panic buying as soon
as other people start to and it's kind
of just a Snowball Effect and that
brings us to the end of the video so uh
what this video is meant to address is
the question I get so often in game and
that is what items should I merge um
it's really it's really hard I don't I
don't understand why people ask me this
because one thing you have to realize as
a mercher if you have good items don't
tell anyone which kind of goes against
the entirety of this video I understand
that but these are a lot more General
items I still have a few items that I
keep to myself and will hold until my
death as if I tell anyone the margins
are ruined so if you find really good
items make sure not to tell people
that's one of the best things to do in
game and I know it is it's contradictory
to everything I've said this video those
are legitimately good merges but
everyone knows of the items there are
some stray items in game that have
really good margins and those are kind
of what I'm focusing more towards with
this comment but one thing that you have
to do when merching is you can't just
take the list of items that I gave you
in this video and hold those as the only
items that you're going to merge you
have to apply the key attributes of the
items I've told you and kind of the
concepts of how they come into the game
how often they're needed uh just there's
a ton of different steps to go through
to try to reapply the items that I've
given you and find other items through
that so there's a little bit of effort
on your part I'm giving you kind of a a
starting base as far as what items are
good and kind of you can look from there
as far as what you want to find but
hopefully this video is helpful
hopefully this addresses any of the
questions if you guys have that you guys
questions that you guys have um in the
future if there's anything you guys want
to know and I mean right now if there's
anything you guys want to know about
merching go ahead and leave those in a
comment I think I'll kind of have this
as a running side series to my main one
for as far as merching goes because um I
know a lot of people have questions as
far as to how merching works and I can't
explain those in the uh progress videos
with merching because you know it would
just be way too long and it would just
be all over the place so hopefully this
video is helpful if it was make sure to
leave a like if you're excited for the
series and the content that I'm putting
out subscribe to the channel and uh yeah
join large exp lamp and game I got a
Discord in the description along with
the Twitter so check out whatever you
please and uh yeah with that said
hopefully you guys have a wonderful day
and
[Music]
peace
that